we've actually never spoken about this
and the fact that we've separated and so
we I don't quite have the language yet
we ran into some problems that we did
not feel that we could work on together
in the same place nor did a lot of other
people think that we should work on it
in the same place and so Martina moved
out
is it a separation is it a divorce where
where the two you have they're not
divorced
we're not yeah yeah that's that's a
really ugly word it's a really hard word
to get around like to eat but there are
going to be fans who are going to say
well did he should cheat did she cheat
is there anything going on that we don't
know about I would say that part of that
is entirely our business only it's one
thing to answer to that personally like
amongst your friends and whatever else
but I don't think that our
responsibility to our fans extends to
talking about what happened inside a
relationship three years ago you said
you're moving out your friends and
family reacted there's part of that that
I definitely don't want to talk about
but goes but I can tell you this when
there are people who absolutely don't
want you to be a couple together anymore
or there are people who are angry at you
that you kind of up being a couple a lot
of people we lost for various reasons
friends and family and whatever and and
it made it made it a little more
difficult what point did you decide to
go public with it even nah we didn't
decide it was just obviously not gonna
be something people were gonna ask about
it eventually thought yeah everybody we
know because the album is quite like
it's very it's there's a lot of like
hurt hurtin songs on there yeah so
people are going to eventually and and
being the married couple in the band
it's like because I'd like to do
interviews yeah until we have to answer
the glue married questions and do it
yeah what's it like being married I'll
call this up so it was like we have to
decide what's it like being separated
and working together that would be the
new Brendan right
yeah but we're not you're not anywhere
near the divorce part you're not looking
at the D word I think that that is a it
comes up only because it's part of like
the inevitable like frustration with
this has been the most frustrating
challenging few years ever because it's
just that ongoing endless huge space
taking question like and especially so
now if we go through the process of
divorcing does that mean that we're
gonna hate each other at the end of it
and blow up our band which is the only
thing that we've been working on
individually we get together can we at
least salvage this thing and do this
thing that we love I think it's fake
well we had some help yes for sure our
therapist wrote a lot of songs did you
guys go through see a therapist Oh
Rhodes did you you'd have to right yeah
yes I don't know if it helped I think
I've come on the no I think it I the
only say way if that it would help when
you go to see a couples therapist is
that you stay together if you don't stay
together then I don't think it's worked
very well